las alarmas sobre afganistán están
encendidas y la situación podría
empeorar el próximo año en términos de
condiciones de vida y de violaciones a
los derechos humanos la onu presentó un
balance sobre la actualidad del país
desde que llegaron los talibanes al
poder según el reporte es crítico el
aumento de la pobreza y la hambruna y
tenis se estima que el 98 por ciento de
los afganos no consumen suficientes
alimentos y una food which is lo que
representa un preocupante aumento del 17
por ciento desde agosto a since august
la economía apunta a la onu está al
borde del colapso tras la retirada del
apoyo de occidente un panorama que ha
llevado al aumento acelerado de los
precios del combustible y que amenaza
las condiciones de vida
a medidas de más afganos luchan por
satisfacer sus necesidades básicas las
personas son situaciones vulnerables se
ven obligadas a tomar medidas
desesperadas como el trabajo infantil el
matrimonio de sus niños para asegurar su
supervivencia y según los informes
incluso a la venta de menores cording
sesión grifols y donde se el 8 al mismo
tiempo preocupa la escalada de violencia
al interior del país más de 100 antiguos
mil de las fuerzas afganas fueron
asesinados y al menos ocho activistas y
dos periodistas han sido ejecutados
desde agosto reanudaron el ciclo de
violencia y venganza los relatos sobre
ejecuciones sumarias y las
desapariciones forzadas particularmente
de funcionarios de gobierno y seguridad
y del desplazamiento de las minorías
revelan sólo un atisbo de su campaña de
miedo de acampe no fe el 2022 llega con
el reto de asegurar los derechos
fundamentales a todos los afganos
especialmente de los más afectados los
niños y las mujeres